a couple of rugby world cups you've been
involved in yeah obviously that 2015 one
was would have been pretty special to be
a part of
yeah 2015 team like look through that
squad that was just
an incredible team to be a part of um
yeah i mean and i was lucky i actually
got to play um quite a lot of minutes at
that world cup um richie had a few
niggles and
the warm-up games so i end up starting
more games and or getting more game time
than i thought i would i was realistic
but
always was i was behind the skipper then
so like any game time i could get was
going to be awesome and
even right from the start of my old
black career i got naming the rugby
championship squad after that island one
and steve hansen pulled me aside instead
you probably won't play any games
[ __ ]
they told me straight up
um
and i was like okay so that completely
changed my attitude and i thought well
i'm here in the all blacks this is a
dream result for me i've just got to try
and be a better i'm going to
use it to be a better rugby player by
the time i finish the week than when i
started training with these guys working
hard
and if i get an opportunity i just go
try and take it
and luckily i got one game off the bench
that yeah
um
and then one game
in india tour
but i actually appreciated that he told
me that rather making my hopes up
so when the team name and camp was like
i'm not gonna be named and then when it
finally did holy
but it taught me also um it it served me
really well for this later part of my
career when i
um do start regularly what young guys
are going through and they sometimes
forget that you've been there or they
don't realize that you've actually been
there too and you've had to go through
those training weeks where you know
you're not playing you've got to help
prepare the team put the team first but
still work hard at your own game to try
and be better yeah yeah even in that
2015 world cup you're behind um the
skipper behind richie but when you
got a start against namibia you were
skipper too weren't you
yes true yeah that is that's right um
and that was just completely out of the
blue i didn't see that coming yeah we
had a short turnaround or at the world
cup was maybe like four days so they
pretty much changed um the teams up and
yeah steve just said oh
won't you be skipping for the game i was
actually walking down the road to get a
haircut
on our day off
steve was driving and he was in a cab he
jumped out
saw me told me not back in the cabin
drove off
so
it caught me off guard massively um and
once like man i wasn't even really like
ready for it i wasn't ready for it at
all i don't think i'd even kept on the
chiefs at that stage um
and
as a result i didn't actually play
overly well against namibia i was too
worried about everyone else which was
just now that i think about that stupid
don't worry about anyone else can they
just write about yourself but um
still awesome learning experience also a
massive privilege obviously um and my
family were over at that world cup so i
got to take them out for a coffee and
tell them in person which was which was
really cool because obviously legends
throughout that squad was it
intimidating at all to be named captain
obviously you're so young you hardly
started you like you admitted massively
i remember um
without a clarity session
so that just come off a game and it was
us who hadn't come off a game
that said that i was going to be skipper
and just before we go away i thought man
i'm going to say something here got in a
huddle
and um see it
was like a lot of us have helped prepare
you guys so i'm talking to the
lights of richie and dan and rito and
kim milam and all these boys
a lot of us we've helped you guys
prepare for these first year games i'll
just ask that you guys help us prepare
the best we can to play and
almost telling them
or trying to ask them the nicest way
yeah
and i'd like to rehearse it in my brain
on the way to
right to the training numerous times on
the bus
oh
i love that stuff and then obviously um
you win that rugby world cup what's that
feeling like
yeah just
just awesome um
i can't really put it into words i i
was the shortest um cap
short test cap of my career actually the
world cup final i got on for 30 seconds
actually i was just about
i'm pretty sure i was just about to go
on i've been asked to warm up which is a
good sign when you're on the bench if
you get asked to warm up what time was
this
i think it was without like 25 minutes
to go
and that's when i had been going on
previous games in the quarter in the
semi
and then
bender got yellow carded oh that's right
yeah
yeah and uh whoa i'll hold that man i
sit back down sit back down
during that time i think the aussies i
haven't listened to linda's podcast yeah
i can't remember exactly but the aussie
school day yeah when binder was off yeah
yeah and they were actually looking
quite good for a moment there okay so i
will leave sam on the bench and then um
after boater you got that right away try
right you can go on now
i think i cleaned a rock off the kickoff
didn't know he pretty much kicked it out
yeah
the life on the bench hey oh yeah life
on the bench and come on bender
who knows if he hadn't who got that card
maybe i would have got a decent run but
it was awesome it didn't honestly didn't
but it didn't bother me because of the
the occasion yeah how awesome it was um
yeah struggle find the words to explain
it
[Music]
it's just a just a special experience to
be part of as a is a 23 year old you
know some good mates and
just some some legends of the game yeah
and then rolling on four years 2019
rugby world cup how did this one compare
for you
um yeah i was really really excited
about this one because um
since
2015 sort of
established myself as the the starting
all black sealant and so this world cup
was
i really wanted to have a
i knew i was part of the squad and i
played a good part but i wanted to have
like more of an impact on on the field
and the big moments when we
helped help help us lift another one
i was
and um
the world cup itself like the experience
in japan
the
but it was awesome the people
um so hot when we first got there i
couldn't believe how hot it was
um but but
loved it all
our campaign was a little bit disrupted
i think we were
in our last pool game there's the
like cyclone which one that went through
yeah typhoon you know ordered something
that went through um so our game against
italy got cancelled
and then we put on a performance against
ireland in the quarterfinal that was
just like close to one of those perfect
perfect games and to be fair in 2015
we'd done the same against
france
so we knew and then
in 2015 we backed up against wales oh
jeez wales we backed up against south
africa so we didn't play overly well but
we we got through it's just like the
difference in performance so we knew
that we played really well against
ireland in 2019 we needed to back it up
um
and that that performance probably
wouldn't look anything like
the one against ireland but we just
needed to get a job done and um
look that week was one of the
probably one of the tougher weeks i've
had as an all black because
i got told on
on the monday night from steve that um i
wasn't going to be starting it's going
to be on the bench
after
i think i'd started every test i've been
available up until that point since 2015
so
that was like
it's tough to swallow um because of the
the magnitude of the game and
where i felt i was in my career and
it hurt
but at the same time i
respected the way he told me um he
rationalized his reasons
around wanting to target their line out
so
um having scooter barrett at six
um
and
[Music]
he gave me a good reason about
uh
come off the bench at the time and i i
just had to accept it and agree um
and then again i said sort of pick
myself up but gave myself that night to
be able to stop to myself and the next
day i was live i'm still a leader in
this team i've got to
prepare the best i can and help the team
and know that i can still have an impact
come off the bench but um
obviously that day we were just beaten
by and went inside that was
that was on another level and that they
were too good for us that day that
um
there still stings to be honest it sucks
um
we didn't get it right and um
no no we had it hurt that i was on the
pine for it and uh
we just didn't have the answers that day
when they
they were coming at us yeah how long did
you get on that one longer than 30
from memory yeah i think i came on at
half time to be honest oh yeah yeah
so so once you've
once you're on that bench and you're
watching that game you're watching
england
absolutely dominating us physically
what are you thinking
i'm just thinking i want to get on there
out there and just
hit some people
huh was chomping a little bit to get out
there and
but
probably in hindsight i was like a
little bit even over eager um
i gave away a penalty for smacking one
of the fully
polo boys slightly off the ball i
thought he was going to get the ball i
just went through the tackle um
just like almost a little bit over
aroused you know
um trying to make an impact trying to
make a statement um
also trying to impact the game you know
like trying to lift us and
do something that could help change the
momentum but um
i don't know yeah
it didn't work out
hey it hurts i can feel it
yeah it does it does um
it does hopefully um
hopefully we can
sort it out next year
yeah and what sort of position do you
think all blacks are in heading into
obviously the 2023 world cup
you look like the last two years have
been pretty disruptive and unique for an
all blacks team
i mean i said 20 only six test matches
last year
plenty of test matches but all on the
road and um
so yeah that i think that as a as a
squad like we're a pretty tight group
because of what what we've been through
and there's a lot of depth it'll just be
about
now
guys really staking their claim for that
starting their starting jersey and
making it their own and sort of going to
another level because if i look at that
2015 world cup squad
i think we'll look back and it's one of
the the great squads that's been
assembled but there's numerous players
who are best in the world in their
position and really dominated their
spots and we're
with certain picks and
that's the the challenge for a lot of us
in this current team is we need to make
some some strides and and take our game
as individuals to just another level
um so that we can
as a team go one go all the way next
year
and we'll world rugby's in a good space
at the moment there's a lot of teams
playing well it's going to be it is
going to be some world cup there's no
real clear favorite on who's going to
win this thing obviously the bookies
have france's favorite um all black
second favorite but um there's probably
a number of up to six or seven teams
that could probably win this rugby world
cup
i agree but we're rugby is so strong but
long gone are those days where
remember they all got to send a team on
india tour and change their team week to
like the whole 15 almost yeah like
man it's a worldwide a great spot and
that
the difference in the styles that
different teams are playing as well and
the different challenges
they present we haven't seen in super
rugby you know we've gone from the kiwis
playing each other to them playing the
aussies and just a slightly different
style of rugby that they play and how
you have to adjust and how to fix your
own game so
yeah exciting times